foreign
[Music]
we got to shoot with RL who is a little
bit younger of a model than I am
pretty sure he's into it see how high my
hair is and I'm getting blown dry
[Music]
what's these two it's a male models
I
love fries
this picture is called waiting for RL
[Music]
coming to me
you were at the cubby hole which is a
fantastic
bullies
um it's a place where Cardinal fans
gather to watch baseball games it also
is home to my favorite urinals
[Music]
and it's a story that I'm very familiar
with because I love a plaid shirt
all right I'll just take a picture with
me oh yeah
[Music]
it's exhausting being a high-fashioned
smiling all day serious business follow
me they said they would be cocaine
[Music]
thank you